Il y a quelque temps,
on avait parlé de ce qu'il se passe dans notre corps quand on devient vieux.
Et je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez,
mais comme tout ça c'était un petit peu théorique,
je vous avais proposer de se livrer a une petite experience.
Pour les choses plus concrètes, voila ce qu'on va faire,
je vais devenir vieux le temps d'une journée et je vous montre ce que ça donne dans une prochaine video
*Générique*
Et bien le moment est venu.
Pour ça, laissez moi juste le temps de me mettre dans la peau d'un personne âgée.
Je reviens.
Romain: Mais c'est incroyable t'as vraiment l'air vieux!
Romain: Croulant ! C'est saisissant.
Julien: Fous-moi le camp.
FOUS MOI LE CAMP.
*transformation*
Voilà, je porte un simulateur de vieillissement,
désormais mes articulations sont raides, mes mouvements sont limités au niveau des mains, des poignets, des coudes, des genoux, au niveau du cou.
Et désormais, j'emploie des termes comme "désormais": je suis vieux.
Ma vue est perturbée par un glaucome, ou par une cataracte, ou par une dégénérescence maculaire.
Et ma petite touche personnelle, -nan, je sais à quoi vous pensez mais c'est pas ça-, c'est pour la presbyacousie, c'est-à-dire la baisse de l'audition.
...et je n'arrive pas à les mettre tout seul.
Voilà ! Maintenant, j'ai 80 ans, vous allez me suivre, je vais vivre ma vie, et on va voir comment ça se passe !
C'est parti.
Voilà, début de la journée qui commence super bien parce que j'ai dormi sur mon canapé, étant donné que ma chambre est à l'étage
et que les escaliers, c'est compliqué.
Je sais pas vous, mais moi la première chose que je fais quand je me réveille c'est prendre une bonne douche pour bien commencer la journée.
Alors c'est parti !
* TIC TAC ... *
Donc erreur: la première chose que je fais quand je me réveille, manifestement, c'est de me lever.
D'habitude je m'en rend pas compte, mais là je me rend bien compte que c'est compliqué !
Allez !
Je... On va faire ça comme ça parce que je peux pas rentrer l'autre jambe.
Bon, alors manifestement ça va être difficile de prendre ma douche comme ça, en attendant de me faire installer une petite cabine,
on va faire ça à l'ancienne, à la moyen âge !
Bah voilà, comme un sou neuf !
Ah on se sent mieux ! Allez, un petit café maintenant.
C'est pas commode.
*sluuuuuurp*
Alors par contre, je sais pas vous mais, moi le café..
Nan par contre là vous venez pas avec moi hein, on est d'accord...
Non. Non, non, vraiment.
*bruit de chasse d'eau*
Bon ben je vais pas vous mentir, c'est pas très pratique non plus.
Hop là
Yo tout le monde, c'est Papy Gaming !
Allez, on part sur un petit Fifa !
Alors...
Woow...
J'y arrive pas du tout !
Ouais! Nan! ok...
Et en plus, je vois rien ! Avec une cataracte, peut être que c'est mieux?
Et bas nan, je vois rien non plus...
Woooo
Putain, c'est pire, je vois rien du tout!
Et alors avec la dégénérécende maculaire, peut être que c'est mieux?
Aha putain ok, donc là, vraiment, je vois absolument rien du tout!
Et j'arrive toujours pas à toucher la manette avec mes doigts.
Bien!
Bon, ça part sur un échec
Bon, j'ai la dalle, je vais me faire un truc à bouffer.
Hop! Mais, c'est qu'on prend l'habitude hein! Allez!
Des bonnes pâpâtes!
On va partir sur un kebab du coup, hein?
Ah putain! Ah bah j'ai réussi!
Alors, un kebab. Où est ce qu'on a ça?
J'comprends pourquoi ma grand mère ne répond jamais du premier coup...
C'est bizarre, parce que avec les bouchons, à l'intéreur,autant, là,  j'entendais tout,
Autant là, avec le bruit des voitures en plus, j'entends plus rien du tout.
Je vais vous prendre un Kebab frite... Pardon?
J'en chie!
Putain! je croie que j'ai marché dans de la merde!
Nan, c'est une feuille.
Putain! Ca y est! On est arrivé!
BOOM!
Ah! Ca j'y arrive!
Bon, c'est un peu froid, on va pas se mentir.
On part sur une arthrite.
Pardon maman.
Putain c'était bon!
Bon, allez maintenant vous venez? je vais faire l'amour!
Nan, je déconne, je pense que ça suffit pour aujourd'hui!
Eh bien je suis épuisé!
Allez, détransformation.
J'arrive pas à claquer des doigts...
Ouuf! Et encore là, c'était qu'une journée et sans toutes les galères de prostates, sans toutes les douleur
et sans tous ces petits trucs qui peuvent encore compliquer la vie quand on est vieux.
Et dont on avait déjà parlé dans la première vidéo.
Alors je sais pas ce que vous retenez de cette expérience,
moi, perso ce que je retiens, c'est que quand on est vieux, tout fait plus compliqué,
même les trucs les plus basiques de la vie quotidienne.
Et ça veut dire que, du coup, il faut sans arrêt trouver des statégies d'adaptation à tous ces changements.
Et ça, c'est épuisant.
Ce que je veux dire aussi, encore une fois, c'est que ça coûte pas cher t'être patient avec les personnes agées
Au lieu de les speeder parce qu'elles vont pas assez vite.
Parce que elles aussi, elles trouvent qu'elles vont pas assez vite!
Sauf que pour elles, c'est toutes la journée, tout le temps!
D'ailleurs, si on veut, on peut même leur donner un coup de main,c'est pas interdit! En tous cas leur proposer.
Parce que, oubliez pas! Demain, les vieux, ce sera vous!
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo!
En attendant, je fais un gros bisou à ma Mémé.
Et à vous aussi!
*générique*